Times are tough, jobs are scarce.
It's risky to be outside
and around others.
It seems like there's very few ways
to make extra money during a pandemic.
So I guess I'll just hunker down
and binge social media
until this all blows over.
Wait, don't these people make money?
How do these people make money?
Streamers, YouTubers, Twitch
stars, how do they make money?
Is it a lot?
Is it a lot of work?
I know, I got to ask somebody in the biz
and I got just the guy, Austin John Plays.
This is your full-time job now, right?
As of November of last year, yes.
This was always just kind
of like a side thing.
Like any money that I made
from doing my videos and whatever else,
I never touched that 'cause
I didn't really think
of that as being like real money.
And then it started
coming in more and more.
And then it was like, I hit my first day
that I broke a grand and I was like,
this is actually gonna be money.
How did the YouTube channel come to be?
When the game Pokemon Sun
and Moon came out for the 3DS
there was like things that
I learned about the game.
And then I wanted to just share
that information with people.
And at the time I didn't have
any way to capture a screen
or anything so I found
like generic footage
and I kind of put it all together
with so much editing and
that video got six views.
And then two days later I made another one
and that one got 12 views.
And then I just started pumping
out more and more content.
And people were like,
this guy knows what he's talking about.
It really just started
building on top of itself.
And then it was like.
My channel really focuses
on tips and tricks.
So I play a straight 18 hours
and I'll finish the game or
get to about the 40 hour mark
and then I'll make my first video.
While I'm going through
I have a giant notepad
and just scribbles everywhere.
And I make these notes of like
the things that stumped me.
So I know the things that
may stump other people.
What do you need to think about
if you're building your YouTube channel?
One, you need to do something
that you're passionate about.
Not that you like,
not that you think you're
going to make money on,
something you're passionate about.
Other thing is something
that other people are passionate about.
It holds a special place to them.
And third is, it needs to be something
that people are going to
seek out information on.
In order to enter into the marketplace,
you either need to be
better than everyone else,
faster than everyone else
or you need to be more
accessible than everyone else.
And you can't be more accessible
'cause it's already on the platform.
Granted, if you understand
how the algorithm works,
which is very similar to
Google Analytics, then yeah,
you can have a little bit of a headstart,
but if you're not doing it faster
and if you're not doing it
better than everyone else
then why should anyone watch your channel?
So my income as a YouTuber
kind of breaks down
to three different ways.
One, which is the bulk of
it, which is ad revenue.
Whenever you go and you watch a video
and then there's an ad and
then you wait five seconds
and you hit the bottom right corner
and then you go onto the next
video or a non-skippable ad
or the video starts immediately,
you get the little
banner ads at the bottom.
Or if you scroll down from the video
the first thing that shows there is an ad.
Those are the four different types of ads
that can appear on every
single YouTube video,
and all of them pay a certain amount.
It varies on lots of
things like the country
of the person who posted,
the country of the person who
watches it, the time of year,
where you are in the quarter,
if there's anything going
on with a reduction in ad revenue.
Like great example, COVID-19
companies weren't spending
as much on advertising so
because of that, CPM went down.
CPM stands for click per thousand
and using the Roman numeral for 1,000.
And that means that for every 1,000 views
you get a certain amount of money.
Now on low ads, when I first started off,
my CPM was 30 cents.
So every 1,000 views, I made 30 cents,
but then once I signed with an MCN
and I started making more quality content
and more engaging content,
some of my better videos
and certain times of the year
I can see CPMs as high as 12 to $14.
And there's a big
fluctuation between, you know
if I post a video when
there's no ads being spent
like January and February.
That's a reason a lot of
your favorite YouTubers
and also TV shows don't
post new videos in that time
of year 'cause ad rates are down.
Why are they gonna make content then?
Instead you're recording
and you're bulking up
for when ad revenue is higher.
The second way that a YouTuber
makes income is support,
crowdfunding, things like that.
When I first started off, Patreon
was really the only option
but then they started
rolling out supporters
and members for YouTube channels.
So whenever I have a live stream
you can click a button and
then you can become a member.
And then you get special
icons next to your name.
I believe they're called
badges or on any video
you can hit the join button
and that helps support the channel.
And then the third aspect
of that would be merch.
And for me, my merch
has been somewhat basic.
In fact, I'm wearing one of my T-shirts
from last year right now.
You have to endure the
times that your first video
gets six views, then you post
it on Reddit and they say,
shut up and then an auto mod bans you.
You have to go through that
because until you go through that
and you discover why you're doing it,
you're not doing it for other people.
You're doing it for yourself.
If you're not loving what you
do, then it's not worth it.
Huh, so make a channel
about something that I'm passionate about.
Oh, sweet.
I guess I can make the channel about that.
Now, how do I grow an audience?
How do I get popular?
It's all about diversification, right?
You have to have a
massive Twitter following.
You have to have a massive
Instagram following.
You have to have a
massive YouTube following.
Of course you have to be on Twitch,
which is the key platform, but
basically any way you can get
in front of your audience, you
can engage with your audience
is going to drive those clicks
which ultimately drives
the advertising revenue
that you get back from
all of these platforms.
It's me and Dan playing video games
and talking in a funny manner over them.
They're not just people
who are good at games.
They are actually people who
are good at online engagement,
online entertainment first and foremost.
You have the right to remain stylish.
Anything you wear can and
will be used against you
in the court of fashion.
The streamer is either very,
very talented at the game.
The best player in the game
is generally going to draw a crowd
'cause people like watching
people who are very good.
On the other hand, they're
either very, very good
or funny, charismatic,
whatever it is on that side.
Oh, no.
You know, it becomes more
of a show where they talk
about other things outside
of the gaming world.
And gaming becomes really just a backdrop
and an excuse to engage
with that audience.
There were those weird
like Ronald McDonald,
like straight to VHS
movies, you remember those?
I'm personable, I'm chatty.
I would kind of, you know, when
boring things were happening
in the game, I would
ramble on about, you know
movies I'd watched or
books I'd read on, you know
or conversations I'd
had and stuff like that.
And so I think being personable
was a big part of that.
It's not just getting
on and playing games.
It's getting on and being an entertainer.
You are putting on a show.
All right now, let me go ahead
and grab the samurai
sword that every gym has.
Okay, he's dead.
To have a larger audience
and to have that audience,
I think, stay with you, you
have to bring something extra.
You know, you have to find your niche.
You have to find what
works and what connects
with the audience and
what makes them laugh
or what makes them keep coming back.
You gotta make it a little
more exciting, all right?
Throw in a hanging Bishop,
have everybody in suspense for a moment.
I think the real, most important thing is,
is to just get used to being on camera.
Like in any sort of performance thing
is get used to talking on camera.
You know, my first few
videos were terrible
but because I sat down and did it
for six to eight hours a day,
I just got used to talking
and I got over that uncomfortable hump.
If you go into Twitch
purely with the expectation
that you're going to make
money, make a job out of it,
have all this growth and
it's going to be great,
you're probably going to
burn out prior to getting
to that point because
there's very little payoff
for a long time, right?
Like, multiple years generally
before you really start to see a payoff.
And so, you know, those first few times
you're streaming, nobody is there.
One person shows up every 30 minutes,
says hi maybe and leaves, right?
Like, it's very discouraging,
I think, for a lot of people.
And so you have to be
there just loving it.
You have to love talking to
yourself when nobody is around
you have to love just the
game that you're playing,
all of that stuff
because it takes a while.
And I think a majority of people burn out
prior to getting to the
profitable point of it.
And there you have it, my
very own YouTube, Twitch,
Discord, and streaming
channels all ready to go live.
It's a veritable social media ecosystem
just on the verge of thriving.
So don't forget to
smash like and subscribe
and visit my Patreon for perks.
Also, go to my merch page.
And one last thing, stay cool, my friends.